[Music]
absence of the comment really
shamah fanb and sing universe independent
on sunday
but I'm different
ap and cold the day laborers from the north
have taken over the work of the day laborers
from the north is to make that suffering visible
so that people know it
a song
a tool  of struggle
[Music]
and
my name is pablo alvarado and I am one
of the founders of the twins of the
north people are
usually projected as
victims but they are also protagonists
of their own destiny and the formation of
the day laborers of the north  it is a form
a form of protagonism my name is
manuel ortiz I am the percussionist of the
group los jornaleros del norte I come here and
legally I come across borders
[Music]
for the simple fact of being blind I did not
qualify to stay in this country
but on the contrary this  it makes me
stronger today I tell you the greatest pride
[Music]
I am moved
that not asking for a 5 from this
country instead of asking for a 5 given 10 20  plus
our music is to take the message to the
whole world so that we don't let ourselves
when someone wants to abuse
[Music] they
should face all over the counter left
space in the fifth face in pectore
[Music]
of detention sandringham making them the
first of the
webmaster documents  on facebook
[Music]
martín
esther beige awareness and for the
protection of the people inside you must
contain context from warner
for water first experience
[Music]
that they were prisoners they were hitting the
window and putting up signs those
who were inside the message was here
we are
and the outside said see you
then this is that moment when it
occurred to us it is time to bring the music to
show them that not only the others and we
also feel them
this type of concerts we have done
with humble town musicians
but also with artists
celebrities so for example we have
opened for reig also se machine and
we have opened for manu chao juanes and
jo  hn legend
a musical note is something universal
[Music
] discrimination for me comes from
many factors color race language
and not having a legal document so you
can live anywhere in the
world
our musical genre is a defense weapon
through  music you can fight
you can achieve and you can defend yourself
[Music]